this week on quadriga the merkel system
no end in sight Angela Merkel has headed
the German government for ten years now
and there's still no likely contender to
take her place at the table German
voters can't seem to get enough of her
Merkel's popularity and opinion polls is
unbroken as the leader of Europe's
economic powerhouse
she's also taken the lead in
international issues playing a decisive
part in the Greek bailout negotiations
for instance what is the secret of
Merkel's success if such a long time in
office good for Germany and for Europe
coming to you from Berlin could Riga the
International debate your host this week
Melinda crane hello and welcome she's
becoming as much of an institution as
her political mentor Helmut Kohl could
she wind up governing as long as he did
and is that a good or a bad thing for
Germany and for Europe that's what we
want to talk about today with three
people who follow German politics very
closely it's a pleasure to welcome
Margaret heckle she is the author of a
best-selling book on Angela Merkel's
approach to governance she served as
head of the politics desk at major
German newspapers and she says Merkel
stands for stability that's why the
Germans trust her in his poll was until
recently the editor-in-chief of the
Berlin daily newspaper date August sytem
she's now preparing to go to Washington
as a correspondent for us for DW Ynez
Paul says it's no longer enough just to
manage crises the way that Merkel does
and our final guest on today's program
Alexander gherla he's the founder
publisher and editor-in-chief of the
German debate magazine the European he
says if Merkel manages to build up a
successor she will go down in history as
the greatest German Chancellor ever tall
words Alexander Gerlach we want to hear
what that is in just a moment but let me
start out by recalling one of the more
notable political moments of this the
summer in Espoo it was a statement by a
state premier that Angela Merkel is
basically unreplaceable the thing that
was especially notable about this is
that he didn't come from her own party
he came from the rival Social Democrats
how in the world is that possible how
did Germany come to that pass
that is a good question I think in a way
he is really right I mean Margaret
heckle he she kind of mentioned it in
her statement it's really her stability
her reliability which the Germans really
love we have to say Germany is doing
very well people you know they're
well-off and they feel safe with her
because she stands for continuity like
no other other politician does I think
when we talk about Angela Merkel we
always have to talk about the opposition
and this is something which is really
lacking in Germany and that place
totally into her own market heckle you
spent time with the Chancellor you've
observed her firsthand what's her secret
well the way I what she she takes a long
time to decide questions and she said
herself that you know she has to think
about them she has to see all sides but
once she's decided she really sticks
with her decision and I think that's
what the Germans value and there's been
a few decisions where that didn't work
like when the energy policy was turned
around and atomic
was phased out but with the rest of it
she's very consistent in what she does
and that really seems to be her secret I
think then the girl laughed leaving
aside your point about the successors
we'll come back to that a bit later but
let's talk about the being the greatest
Chancellor in history potentially is
that because she's a great state's woman
or simply a very very canny politician
well I mean you have to be a sort of
candy if you want to be like at that
popular at all times if you are a
Chancellor like for ten years but what
what I think is if you look at the
Federal Republic of Germany the post-war
history it's mostly most of the time the
Conservatives govern on that level it's
a different under states where the
Social Democrats have have good polls
and we're at this point they they they
have the vast majority of all prime
ministers in on the state level on the
federal level however as Ben's just like
in 1989 when Cole was not re-elected
it's just because he didn't find in time
a proper successor of his because he was
back then sixteen years in the office so
what I'm saying is that the
Conservatives
the Germans for some reason think that
the Conservatives apart from Angela
Merkel are the are the party that
governs them on that state level in his
poll again that question states woman or
canny politician what do you think
drives Angela Merkel is it a vision for
Germany for Europe or is it largely
domestic political can I have to say I
don't see any vision which is bigger
than her own power she wants to stay in
power she's a fantastic power player she
really knows how to do that that's the
reason why she survived the last 10
years we always have to keep in mind
that she came from the outside her way
is quite interesting she really came as
an outsider and to come into this party
as an outsider to stay for that long you
have to be so talented when it comes to
power but and this is my concern about
the future regarding Germany in Europe I
don't see any vision of Europe she's all
about the domestic issues of Germany
she's that's why the Germans love her so
much
Germany comes first and then there's a
pretty long way nothing and then might
come Europe and then might come the rest
of the world and I think in this crisis
we're seeing with grease we're seeing
also with Syria and all the wars going
on we are we seeing with Israel and
Palestine this won't be enough for the
next ten years
do you agree no I think she will it
changed the country and ten years have
been a long time and if you look at
Germany now and Germany is ten years
back Germany has become much more open
to integration Germany has become much
more open to interacting on a world
scale Germany has become much more open
to in towards European integration and
she really did change her party which is
which was a totally other thing when she
took over so what she doesn't do and
that's why people Rhian mistake this is
that she communicates what she wants
she's not a person who stands there and
says this is what I want ABCD and this
is how we're gonna do it that's not her
style she decides on her own and she
doesn't come she that's probably her
major fault that she doesn't communicate
it well but at the end she usually gets
what she decided on Alexander girl
Margit heckle says the Chancellor really
changed her party well she changed it in
part by co-opting topics and movements
from other parties for example green
energy or the minimum wage topics that
were very much SPD Social Democratic
topics she co-opted into her own party
thereby setting in motion a kind of D
politicization of the German landscape
as a whole well I mean there seems to be
a tendency of major parties to just come
closer to each other in their positions
I guess to a certain extent back then
you had that in the United States as
well the thing is here what what what
Margaret said is Merkel she has a very
consistent political style so she is
she's they keep taking baby steps
sometimes but that allows her to just
integrate like other positions because
she's not saying hey we adopt the whole
Social Democratic agenda but she says
hey look maybe that aspect of minimum
wage isn't so bad after all
and she gets that step-by-step and that
this is the second thing what is just
said because
the German opposition is very weak and
the Social Democrats do not stand at
this point for a very consistent Polish
bad policy but in this poll does that
have drawbacks for the political system
as a whole is there for example the the
threat of a rise on the far right
because there's no longer a strongly
defined conservative party but in fact a
sort of a a vast CDU a big tent that can
cover any topic on any area of the
spectrum absolutely this has an impact
on the really on the landscape on the
political on the Democratic landscape I
would say you know we hardly have any
deep discussions in our Parliament you
know there aren't really fights for
things are you right am i right what
kind of an idea what kind of an
understanding do we have of the role of
Germany of the role of Europe of the
role of the United States and this is a
problem I think we are losing Germany is
losing the ability to really go through
deep discussions within the political
system but also within society Michael I
have to say that for me as an American
it's quite astonishing you know in the
u.s. these days you would definitely
know how any individual in your circle
of friends voted party politics are so
polarized they are so defining for the
u.s. that is absolutely not true in
Germany is that the work of this
Chancellor well I think it's the work of
society Society German society has
become a lot less ideological than it
was 10 years or 20 years back and then
the big battles had in 410 and that's
when you know in Germany you could say
you were for green energy or against
green energy you were for conscription
or against conscription nowadays
everybody's for green energy you know
and nobody when when conscription came
down nobody said ah I want to fight for
it I want to fight for it you know
everybody said okay fine we're just
gonna go along and so I know why I'm a
can really fits it very well so the
question really is is it her or is it
society I mean who reacts on whom it
really hard to say it as Paul told us a
second ago that she's worried about the
implications for the future let's take
look at those implications what does the
era of Macko
mean for Germany also in the future it's
not just a record heat wave that's
responsible for the widespread lethargy
in Germany drunk on its economic success
the country seems to have settled down
for a long siesta
leaving researchers to find the reasons
for the deep sleep that has befallen it
materially Germany is doing better than
it has in years the economy is booming
thanks to robots and to migrants they'll
keep working even in the heat
Europe's crises seem to have passed
Germany by let the others tighten their
belts
mutti or mommy as Merkel is dubbed has
it all under control
she stands for the stability that
Germans like best some critical voices
say this complacency is dangerous but
their alarm calls are going unheeded is
Germany going to sleep through the
future
Alexander gherla we were all praising
the virtues of stability just now but is
there a point at which that stability
tips over into complacency and does in
fact blind the country to the need to
make adjustments for the future I'd say
so and we see that in particular in in
economy where the digitalization of
digital economy the internet so to speak
to startup culture it's not really
reflected to my opinion accordingly to
its importance for the future of this
country and I think the government
decide it's it's a social democrat
Minister of economics but also from miss
michael carmichael who is also in charge
of the whole government they just you
know they day they argue about whether
or not you if Amazon is a good thing or
a Facebook is a good thing but on the
other hand that's just creating jobs and
if that's the future of economy and I
think we will not be selling our cars to
China in 40 years time they may all
drive Tesla by then in his poor how much
of the prosperity and stability that
Germany has been enjoying particularly
since the financial crisis is actually
Chancellor Merkel's achievement doesn't
it actually rest to an at least equal
degree upon the achievements of her
predecessor Gerhard schröder
in pushing through very very tough
social welfare most definitely she's
like harvesting the so called agenda
2016 where we really had brutal cuts in
our social system and she knows that and
she plays said as she always does very
smoothly and people think it's something
she really achieved that is a problem
because I think you're totally right on
the technical side and the economic side
but I I think it's also or even more so
a problem when it comes to prepare this
cantaloup a country of shifts which the
country will face I'm sure that you are
talking about the the wealth and the
economic success
living or experiencing right now in
Germany this will change within the next
two or three years we're looking at
China we don't know what this crisis
will mean immediately here and you asked
just a couple of minutes ago
how what this could mean for the right
wing power parties and I am indeed
indeed deeply afraid but this political
atmosphere with no culture of discussion
means when it comes to a more insecure
economical situation in this country for
the up race of really right-winged and
maybe even extreme left-wing parties
Michael would you agree is a complacent
Germany sleepwalking toward a future
that's not so bright yeah absolutely the
danger of complacency is definitely
there and that's but that's in every
society when things run smoothly you
don't want to change and actually you
can really only push change true when
things are not running smoothly when
there's a crisis and that's what we've
seen in the last couple of years in
Germany reforms were only done when
there was a crisis it really had to hurt
and so in a way that really is a danger
and I my my reading of Merkel is that
that's for her one of the reasons why
she thinks you're Europe s to stand as a
unified region in the world because only
if Europe is unified and has one
currency namely the euro it can really
stand up and have his heads have its
voice heard in twenty thirty years time
when China is going to be so much more
important than it's now and we don't
know what's going on with the United
States but you know when world global
politics really do shift and so that's
behind her European policy and there she
is in the midst of a crisis so that's
not really clear how it's gonna play out
but that's what's in your mind in in
governing through that crisis Linda Mae
Mae at one point I think you are half
right when you say changes can only be
my made with big pressure I mean if it
would be in a better situation Germany
we could have an opposition which would
be
to build up this pressure you know to
show the needs of changes but as the
opposition that is beneath the Social
Democrats and also the Green Party and
also the Left Party are so weak this
voice is really missing in the political
discourse so therefore it's miracle and
only her who is really shaping the
discourse Alexander Gerlach coming back
perhaps just briefly to Marco's personal
characteristics I sometimes have the
sense that part of the safety and
stability that Germany attributes to the
Chancellor has to do with her own
personal aura including an aura of
absolute incorruptibility and modesty do
you think that's right does that does
that carry meaning for the Germans
that's a hundred percent true what you
say I mean you would not you would not
think air of being as a corrupt person
she's very modest she's not fancy in in
her style she's not over exaggerating
any any feature of any sort of her
character so she personifies the the
middle-class woman that were persons are
to speak that most of the Germans feel
attracted to in terms of reflection of
themselves which basically means she's
still authentic after ten years in power
and actually that's not none a small
feat to be still authentic after ten
years in power you know name any other
politician who you say still authentic
after such a long time the traits that
are often mentioned that go with that
authenticity are that she's a scientist
she's a woman she's from the east of
Germany and she's a Protestant what if
any of those would you say is really
determinative of her management style
I think the scientists side is really to
be reckoned with because you know
scientists they work differently than
politicians to a scientist it's trial
and error you know you try something it
works fine if it doesn't work you try
another thing and so she's not
embarrassed to go for the second way to
go for the third way you know whereas a
politician would say oh my god the first
way doesn't work I am embarrassed it
doesn't work she says okay let's try
something else and that's been what
people
at the beginning of her chance of ship
said she doesn't know what she's doing
she doesn't know what she's doing
I think she always knew what she was
doing but in the way she was taking you
know that was the scientist approach and
after all she most of the times she got
what she wanted and of course that is
exactly why the critics say she doesn't
lead yes simply muddling through let's
take a look at the Chancellor's
leadership for five years in a row
Angela Merkel has topped the Forbes list
of the most powerful women in the world
and that's the way Germans have gotten
used to seeing her representing German
interests in Europe and keeping its
unruly leaders in line for the good of
Germany and Europe of course
service like former Foreign Minister
yashka Fisher of the Greens take a
critical view he said recently Mackel
and shrubbler showed no compromise at
the talks in Brussels
Germany was more important for them than
Europe that could be the end of a great
idea
some critics accused Merkel of being
short on ideas both for the future of
Germany and for the future of Europe in
his part I take it you might agree with
that but the fact is doesn't matter
faced a very difficult dilemma she gets
all these calls for Germany to take a
leading role including from the US where
you will soon be working and on the
other hand as soon as Germany takes a
strong stance
people say oh Germany's returning to its
bad old role as a regional hegemonic
power I'm very thankful that you raised
this point it's true sure it is
difficult but on the other hand we have
to say Germany now is in this position
where we have to take leadership where
we have the responsibility to take
leadership and I actually really do
agree with your official in that point
and that America and also our finance
minister sharply mainly think about
domestic issues Germany comes first and
then comes the rest of the world then
comes Greece and then comes Europe one
could say okay that's that's what she
has to do because it's the Chancellor of
Germany but she is also a strong leader
in Europe and I think if she really
would have a vision of Europe she would
say okay now we take Europe first
because we as Germany do need Europe
anyhow where could and should Mackel
have led or be leading in a different
way well actually I mean and European
discourse I think she did too cried a
good job and also in tackling the crisis
which started in 208 I mean that's been
that's been we were referring to the
Social Democrats again that 2010 and but
we we have to keep in mind that there
has been a huge crisis of its own to be
faced by this government by this
Chancellor so we don't have to go back
to the social-democratic again dad to
say look she's harvesting that I I would
disagree with enos in that regard I
think the scientific style of try an
error a combine that ever be
my opinion as a woman who is not just
playing according to that male rules of
dominance and I own this here and I'm
them so this is what was the fact that
the failure of a McCool in the end to
not to resign or find a successor I
think that's something what makes she an
extraordinary leader so I don't see the
lack of leadership and actually if I see
that if I may say that in a very
self-critical way to our industry as
journalists we have problems in this
country for having media outlets who do
not make it in 10 years time to
transform the newsrooms in a digital one
so how can we dare to just say Oh Merkel
she didn't do that in proper time to
just tackling the whole euro crisis our
title of this program is Mackel no end
in sight
Margaret echo do you see her governing
for yet another term that's already
being discussed all the though the
election isn't for quite quite some time
I think we're likely to see her serve 16
years as her mentor do I don't know but
as your position is this week as we've
been talking about and that's what it is
everything seems set for another victory
and I mean we've been talking about this
term that she might you know hand over a
midterm or something like that and but
then again the euro crisis is not over
so there's a real there's a real goal
there to you know I see it through and
her name will be tied to this crisis and
the historians will judge her on that so
given the way she acts given the way she
thinks it's quite reasonable that you
know she's gonna be there for another
couple of years and see that see this
crisis true yeah
Alexander girl a few said if she
appoints a successor but the fact is she
has destroyed almost every other
potential rival within her party there
is no successor out there is there well
I mean she I mean there have been I mean
there's a controversy about how she got
rid of these people but it's been man of
her generation it's obvious when she
will leave the office she's in her
mid-60s I mean allegedly when we say she
makes another term but I think the polls
indicate then she would need people from
the generation behind so to speak so
that's actually the guys she who got
lost the last 10 years they are not
they were not the Papa Beulah so to
speak there has to be a new generation
in a school what do you think Merkel no
end in sight and is that a good thing or
a bad thing for you both I actually do
disagree that her predecessor has to be
much younger it really depends on the
situation
maybe someone it depends really on the
crisis maybe someone wants really some
really experienced politician and not a
new kid on the block and mecha did many
things well very well she didn't do some
mistakes that is also great but I think
that it's good as time is changing the
fast in the world so complex that
Germany gets a new leader within the
next four years it wouldn't be good if
she also would take a lead for 16 or 17
years as hem would call it you want to
throw any names into the ring no it's
far too early to do that I really do not
have any names I mean people talk about
our defense minister also the underline
but I have no idea Myra Tekel many
politicians find it very hard to know
the right time to go would you say that
is true of Chancellor Merkel well it's
certainly the real art of politics to
find your way out in a dignified way I
don't know I don't know it's really very
hard to say I she might have the
possibility to do so more than others
but after all it's an open question
thank you very much to all of you for
being with us thanks to all of you out
there for tuning in see you soon bye bye
you